the people of old yharnam were dying
they called it ashen blood a baffling
sickness that ravaged the town it's not
hard to imagine what the symptoms were
the only treatment they had were these
little white tablets and even these only
offered temporary relief they want to
cure not by a long shot so when the
healing Church appeared proclaiming
salvation via their blood transfusions
it probably came at the perfect time
the people were cured of their ashen
blood ailment and the church's miracle
cure became the pride of yharnam and the
envy of outsiders people would come from
far and wide for a chance at blood
ministration and the healing Church
gained unprecedented power through the
faith of its people only don't you think
this is all too convenient
that there would be a sickness of the
blood that it would only affect the
populace of old yharnam that the healing
church was ready and waiting with
transfusions that could cure anything no
it's possible the healing Church
poisoned the populace of old yharnam
with the ashen blood ailment the poison
knife tells us that poison was a weapon
of the church the antidote tablets that
the populace used to treat ashen blood
cure poison and underneath old yharnam
runs a water supply that could have been
easily tainted what better way to create
a community ready to accept the miracles
of the healing Church but regardless of
what you believe it's a fact that the
ashen blood ailment eventually triggered
the spread of the beastly scourge and
since old yharnam was one of the first
places treated with the old blood it's
people were among the first to turn the
hunters workshop existed to fight the
scourge of beasts it was one branch of
the church run by Gherman the first hunt
the hunter's workshop itself consisted
of factions each with different ideas on
beast hunting one of these factions were
the Powder Keg hunters bearers of the
Powder Keg batch the Powder Keg hunters
are credited with creations such as the
cannon the rifle spear the stake driver
and perhaps even Molotov cocktails but
these are unlocked when you attain their
batch the late powder kegs had a motto
if a weapon ain't got kick it just ain't
worth it they were labeled heretics by
the rest of the workshop who spurned
their crude genius but he Clanton either
head character one of the powder keg
hunters was Jura he was said to have
been uncommon ly kind and dreadfully
foolish and he wasn't just any hunter he
was a hunter of the dream the hunters
dream sustained him allowing him to
suffer little consequence from death
enabling him to venture out into the
waking world from the safety of another
realm who knows for how long he did this
and for what reasons perhaps he saw a
great good in what the workshop was
doing their hunting of beasts kept the
populace safe though it can't have been
too long before everything got out of
hand a couple of people turning into
beasts was manageable but when the Blood
Moon descended the line between man and
beast was blurred and old yharnam one of
the first places treated with the old
blood became severely overrun by beasts
at this point secrecy was impossible and
no longer required the only way to
contain the beasts was to launch an
all-out assault on all the Arnim and who
better for the job than the Powder Keg
hunters old yharnam was sealed and set
ablaze to prevent the spread of the
beastly scourge the town burned and so
did the men women children and beasts
within it we find the charred hunter set
within the ruins worn by the hunters who
swept through after the raging flames
subsided to hunt victims of the scourge
who survived the inferno it vividly
mentions the stench of singed blood the
weaponry attire and over-enthusiasm of
the powder kegs was clearly visible in
the smoking debris that remain
there's little doubt that they were
responsible but the hunters did not
perform this purge eagerly in fact we
see a certain reluctance in the notes
left behind the red moon hangs low and
beasts rule the streets are we left no
other choice than to burn it all to
cinders time passes and central yharnam
becomes the heart of the city and old
yharnam becomes this distant memory that
lies smoldering and forgotten but when
we ventured down into the ruins of old
yharnam we find that one human still
remains within Jura
you're a hunter didn't you see the
warning turn back at once old yharnam
burned and abandoned my men is now home
only two beasts they are no heart turn
back the hunter will face the half juror
felt defeated by the state of old
yharnam so much so that he renounced his
hunter's vows and pledged never to kill
another beast this kind foolish man
found his true calling in protecting the
beasts of yharnam from the hunter he
used to be you are still mad at us
which is where
I should think you still have dreams
well the next time you grieve there's
some thought to the half no one truly
knows the hunts purpose it is watched
over by a man who does not wish to be
there and it's inhabited by a doll who
exists to serve you there is no
explanation for why we venture out and
kill for Jura old yharnam was his
realization that hunters are no better
than the beasts that they've slain and
it's true really if a beast is
characterized by its mindless thirst for
blood
then our hunt is really any different
some beasts are even capable of speech
and a reason yes you call me a beast a
beast would you know I didn't ask for
this
you hunters have got more blood on your
hands I no longer dream but I was once a
hunter - there's nothing more horrific
than a hunt in case you fail to realize
the things you hunt they're not beasts
they're people you're not hunting beasts
it's you you're the Beast
just think about what you're doing it's
at a madness one day you will see